okay let me ask you this I know that you
were completely fixated on Harrison Ford
would you rather have him on the podcast
or someone who played James Bond because
I know that like India Jones versus
James Bond
what if I said Daniel Craig's outside
but Harrison Ford's also outside but
only one can come in I hope you're gonna
ask us yes double team Cowboys and
Aliens they were in a movie together
they're promoting it decades later yeah
yes yeah I think I would take
love James Bond but you've got Indiana
Jones and Han Solo there yeah you would
you would lend it you would let them
London Bridge you I mean oh my God are
you kidding she's not wrong uh can you
explain what that is what am I doing you
know my dad occasionally listens to this
podcast Sona would you explain what what
that meant I just think people should
Google it no I think you should explain
it's when well it's also called an
Eiffel Tower uh for people God you're
learning how many cities have you had
weird sex in yeah so wait so what is it
it's one from the back one from the
front and they're high-fiving each other
yeah you are you are bridging and they
are the apparatus or the Eiffel Tower in
there so Harrison Ford and Daniel Craig
are doing uh Matt Gourley and uh from
one from both ends and they're
high-fiving each other and that's called
an Eiffel Tower and a London Bridge
because they're high-fiving yeah okay I
know I understand I understand it's just
the way it has to happen this is the
only way it can happen then I'm in
and by by in I mean they're in they're
in they're in all right I'm glad we uh I
didn't know where we were going with
today's conversation but I'm very
satisfied well which one's the doing the
bridge and which one's doing the tunnels
you know what I mean like who am I
facing uh Harrison Ford yeah and then
Craig's back
and then they're high-fiving
I'm sure that visually I have to say all
those years you were my assistant you
had an encyclopedic knowledge of all
these insane crass sexual positions yeah
and you knew all the insane names for
them and they were things like it's
Superman with an eye patch yeah you know
it's it's uh the California potato chip
the uh
stop making me explain these things
there's kids probably who are listening
what's a California potato chip it's
when you
and in the morning you peel it off and
you make them eat it oh I know that is a
dry back
okay this there needs to be a sensor
here yeah there is his name is Adam
sacks he's in the corner yeah
I think I need to go home now okay can I
just ask one more question why is it got
to be California that's a good question
I don't I don't know the answer to that
why is a Cleveland steamer from
Cleveland okay you are the filthiest
person I ever met Sona you know all this
stuff why is a rusty trombone some guy
named Rusty yeah because you always come
in and say oh man you know I got for the
donkey punch and I'd be like what are
you talking about you have your
knowledge of the Civil War you know
James Bond and I know you know I know
that stuff I know about the rusty Trump
trombone and that stuff you have the
power to stop this at any time you want
to read it and start making it go yeah
okay make it stop I can't believe we had
this filthy talk just before introducing
one of Rock's most vicious
heavy metal drummers oh
God he's probably aghast backstage I
like say backstage oh my goodness
they're talking about the California
potato chip I'm horrified